[Musique]
je pense que ce service universel pour
moi il est un peu là la réponse globale
de ce qu'on doit faire on ne sait pas un
service militaire a évidemment on
revient pas aux années où nous avons
fait je pense que monsieur pareil a fait
l'armée
non non c'est je pense séjour citoyens
sportif et citoyen pour notre jeune des
15 17 ans lycéen sortie de seconde et je
trouve que c'est intéressant à deux
niveaux d'abord sur l'alternance
l'encadrement est constituée de gens de
l'éducation populaire dans mon staff de
vingt-et-une personnes j'ai des gens de
l'éducation populaire qui sont qu'un sur
le côté pédagogique d'autres et sur le
type un cadrage et des militaires dont
moi policiers effectivement qu'un cadre
ont effectivement ce ce dispositif avec
des jeunes de bafa qui sont les tuteurs
de des jeunes qui vient de participer à
cet événement voilà je trouve qu'il a un
véritable terrien véritable et télé
parce que on arrive à faire collaborer
je dirais les adultes de diverses
visions de la société puisque je vous
disais il ya des militaires des
policiers des éducateurs populaires et
autres et en même temps c'est
transmettre des messages de citoyenneté
c'est assez jeune et je pense que c'est
important ça représente tout ce jour
tout le monde le sait avec une quinzaine
de jours ensuite de missions d'intérêt
général donc voilà ça fait un mois ça
peut paraître peu mais je trouve que ça
allait tirer moins pédagogique pour
notre jeunesse a priori voir une
organisation de d'une mixité sociale et
géographique
j'aurais tendance de va a trouvé ça
plutôt plutôt bien sauf que je regarde
maintenant ce qui sait ce qui s'est
passé
monsieur dit c'est pas militaire
regardez toutes les images qui sont fait
dessus
elles ne sont pas exclusivement
militaire j'ai rien contre les
militaires et d'ailleurs l'engagement
des jeunes ya une partie de notre
jeunesse qui bien sûr à une appétence
absolument légitime à pouvoir servir
sous les drapeaux dans le chai les
pompiers ou autre ce qui me dérange
énormément
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le service
universel devient l'alpha et l'oméga de
tout ce qui se peut faire en politique
de jeunesse et c'est terrible c'est à
dire que tous les mets mes confrères
et ans qui travaille dans les services
d'état a organisé dans les services de
la jeunesse
géré par la jet va témoignent tous
quasiment que dès lors qu'il s'agit de
et seniors on leur demande de poser le
stylo de faire ça et d'abandonner à peu
près tout ce qu'ils avaient en cours on
voit bien que financièrement il ya
beaucoup de crédit sont fléchés sont
fléchés sur le et ses nus et c'est
surtout ans à que le smp nous dérange
nous dérange voilà moi je pense que
c'est à une véritable valeur ajoutée
dans le sens où si on est amené à faire
ce type de d'action avec des jeunes qui
sont encore une fois volontaire je pense
que c'était c'est en même temps un avoue
un aveu je dirais d'échec du monde d'une
partie du monde de l'éducation populaire
il faut être clair que qui a souvent
pensé être les seuls en comment dire en
autorités de prendre en charge les gars
mer il ne faut pas s'étonner d'abord qui
les associations qui prennent évidemment
le relais sur le terrain et deuxièmement
que que ses nuits à paris à paris
puisque c'est une réponse je pense à
notre incapacité de façon générale je me
mets dedans attention je ne jette pas la
pierre à jeunesse et des sports ali âmes
ça ils en sont responsables aussi au
même titre que l'éducation nationale et
que les familles en fait on peut faire
le plan général de l'échec général de de
tous ceux qui ont essentiellement charge
cette jeunesse et je pense que c'est
cette initiative ces initiatives est un
moyen de remettre du sens à notre
jeunesse et et c'est pour ça encore une
fois je que je suis totalement magazine
sur ce dispositif c'est pour ça que je
pense que je regrette d'ailleurs
monsieur n'adhère pas vraiment encore
que je ne trouve pas complètement
négatif au projet mais je trouve
effectivement un peu dommage qu'ils
aient c'est a priori qui plus est venant
de jeunesse et sport ça c'est quelque
chose qui m'interpelle à l'ambition
c'est que une tranche d'âge
une cohorte de
deux tranches d'âge le ifas chaque année
c'est évalué à 800 milles gamin qui
devrait dans le déploiement a participé
aux essais nu chaque année 800 milles on
peut se poser vraiment la question des
infrastructures
il ne nous a pas échappé que les
militaires ne sont plus du tout partie
prenons il n'ouvrait pas les casernes
tiers chloé c'est nul c'est fait dans un
premier temps sur des centres des
centres existants ou des 10es et
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt le modèle est
ce qu'on va faire 30 fois les centres où
les lycées j'ai un peu de doute qu'elle
que fait-on de ceux qui auraient une
appétence pour les ong qui en fait on
pour ceux qui ont une appétence pour
pour pour les arts pour la musique us
qui sont aussi des choses sont
importantes pour nos sociétés que fait
tôt pour les gens qui sont intéressés
par le sport
que fait-on pour ces jeunes qui au
pourrait s'engager et vous et vous avez
compris qu'aujourd'hui en a vraiment
besoin pour pour la santé auprès de nous
personne âgée dans les hôpitaux
voilà pour exemple nous avons au moins
trois départements en gironde en
bretagne où pour le pour faire ça les
personnels sont réquisitionnés trois
jours avant
est ce bien sérieux